autre conflit très meurtrier celui qui
sévit au darrefour depuis un an et demi
la communauté internationale accentue la
pression sur le Soudan accusé d'avoir
armé les milices qui sèment la terreur
au darrefour Kartoum demande du temps
pour régler la situation mais l'ONU
brandit déjà la menace de sanction David
Arnold ils sont de plus en plus nombreux
à rapporter d'horribles histoires comme
ces quatre femmes battu et violé elles
sont venues se réfugier au Tchad avec
200000 autres soudanais
le Darfour voisin une région grande
comme la France ici les jand des
miliciens arabes à la solde du
gouvernement ont lancé une campagne de
terreur depuis 2003 les victimes des
paysans noir chrétiens accusés de
rébellion début juillet les Nations
Unies ont demandé aux autorités
soudanaises un désarmement des milices
peu de progrès ont été
constatés il va falloir juger s'ils ont
respecté leurs engagements s'ils l'ont
fait sérieusement et après bien s le
Conseil de sécurité décidera s'il faut
prendre d'autres mesures pour accentuer
la pression sur le gouvernement
plusieurs diaines de milliers de civils
serai déjà Mor million d'autesent dans
des camp les prir on sont arriv sur
place mais la catastrophe humanitaire
risque de saggraver avec la saison des
pluies embar sur leses g des avoir à
l'étranger rien n fait le gouvernement
soudanais rejette les
critiques
nous n'avons pas besoin de
résolution nous avons besoin de temps
pour mettre en place l'accord passé avec
les Nations Unies le 3
juillet pour l'opération humanitaire les
États-Unis ont débloqué 100 millions de
dollars l'Europe en a proposé le double
il manque encore 200 millions la
Grande-Bretagne a parlé d'une assistance
militaire offre immédiatement rejeté par
le Soudan